most of us play the from software games
to experience some of the best boss
designs in all of video games we go up
against some monstrosity of a character
and we just think to ourselves there's
absolutely no way i can ever beat this
thing and then the thrill that you get
after you do defeat something that crazy
is why we play these games and eldon
ring has some of the best boss designs
i've ever seen so today we're gonna be
ranking all of the main bosses of elden
ring all of the remembrance dropping
bosses because if we tried to do every
boss in elden ring we would be here for
hours on it there's a lot of reskins
reused bosses that we just don't need to
go over and right off the rip this is my
opinion if you have your own opinion
leave it down in the comments or make
your own video because depending on your
build or what kind of player you are you
may have had a completely different
experience than i did with some of these
bosses that i liked or didn't like the
factors that go into the bosses are you
know lore boss design the way it looks
the boss arena the combat design pretty
much everything so let's get into it we
are going to start with godric the
grafted for me godric is an absolute
s-tier boss while it isn't the most
difficult boss in the game not by a long
stretch the lead up through stormville
castle is freaking amazing the boss
arena that he's in leading to his throne
and a just completely destroyed bridge
to it is amazing the music for godric is
one of the best in the game his
character design with all the arms all
over him the big thick legs using the
dragon in stage two his voice lines that
he does are so memorable so cool godric
is a fun fight well designed in an
amazing area leading up to it the lore
behind him is incredible as well for me
there's nothing wrong with this boss
every time i fight him i have a good
time and with a lot of these bosses they
do not have to be difficult to get an s
tier he's got some difficulty behind him
but once you learn all his mechanics
just like all of these bosses they're
much easier obviously but i honestly
cannot think of a negative with godric
he's just awesome he's a spectacle he
was one of the main bosses in the
trailers leading up to the game and i
can see why easy s tier for me ranala
queen of the full moon now i don't know
about you guys but i found this boss to
be very weird stage one is interesting i
don't think i've ever done a boss where
i have to beat up kids or whatever weird
rebirthing that's going on at least with
the builds that i've made this boss is a
complete pushover difficulty wise the
only thing that i've ever died to in
this boss fight at least in stage one is
falling chandeliers they'll one shot you
in the little kids breathing fire and
throwing books at you on the ground they
don't really do anything they do barely
any damage at all you have to have three
of them to have ronald fall out of her
weird golden ball and then she just lays
on the ground while you smack her it's
stage one is weird stage one i would
give like a c experience it's cool lore
wise it's a weird gimmick but i don't
really enjoy it i'm just kind of waiting
for stage two stage two probably the
best boss arena in the game where you're
just you know all ocean water with the
full moon in the background is a
beautiful spectacle of a boss arena and
then her move set really opens up and
shows how powerful of a sorceress she
really is and she has lots of different
moves but she has that factor where she
just kind of hovers away from you i
really don't like chasing down bosses in
any souls game but it makes sense for a
character she's a sorceress doesn't have
any armor makes sense for her to back
off and play at a distance so i'm not
gonna put any points off for that i
think stage two is an a but stage one
kind of brings the entire experience
down to a b for me it's just not super
memorable like i'm literally only going
there in my playthroughs to have the
rebirthing process be available to me
that's that's pretty much it stage one
brings it down stage two is awesome but
definitely not anywhere near s tier so
i'm just going to put her at a b regal
ancestor spirit i absolutely love this
fight i don't know about everybody
else's experience with it because it's a
pushover there's almost no difficulty to
either one of the designs of these
bosses there's one that's weaker this
one is the remembrance that we get that
has a little bit more moveset to it and
it can heal itself now the lead up to
the fight i think is annoying more than
cool but with the lore of nocron like
nocron itself is freaking awesome and
then the first experience i had with it
it was cool to see what would happen
getting to this boss fight by opening up
the bonfires or the little fires you
have to light up but music is probably
the best in the game definitely one of
the best in the game boss design is
really cool just this moose or deer i
think it's a moose but every time i
fight this boss i think it's awesome and
a spectacle i'm gonna put it at an a i
don't think it's quite an s to your boss
because it's not like absolutely
incredible but i love it every time i do
it it's beautiful i think it's well
designed i don't find any part of it
really annoying the boss arena is
beautiful don't know much of the lore
the only thing i've really noticed is
that the little spirit animals walking
around when the regal ancestor wants to
heal it takes the souls from those
animals and they fall over and die which
i find very interesting i think it's an
a tier fight there's not a lot of
negatives to it oh we got astral next
there's actually another one of these in
the consecrated snow fields but the main
one the remembrance that we get is at
the end of ronnie's questline i actually
don't know how i feel about this boss
like the the boss design itself is
amazing it's the coolest scariest
looking thing i've seen in a video game
lore behind it's really cool either it
was here well before the golden order
came to the lands between or it crashed
down in a meteor the move set with it is
interesting it reminds me a lot of the
elden beast i really don't know how i
feel about this boss because i don't
think of it often it's not a super
rememberable fight but the design itself
is insane i think i'm gonna put him at a
b there's really not a ton going on
there to really make him any higher than
that i don't particularly remember the
music within it the lore is awesome
moveset's cool like where it whips you
with its tail and it has all of those
you know gravity spells that it wants to
use on you but i get the same vibe with
it that i do with ranala it's it's not
super memorable it has some cool aspects
to it but i don't think it's any higher
than a b for me alright now we got
reichard i
absolutely
love this fight i'm putting reichard at
an s now i know reichard's a gimmick
fight but it is a spectacle to do i love
doing it every time the lead up to the
boss where you have to do all of the
volcano manor assassinations is sick
volcano manor itself is such a vibe it's
so cool the boss arena that it's in with
the ground covered in corpses and bones
of all of the people they've eaten and
then looking up in the skies just like
chandeliers everywhere and then the boss
design itself is so freaking cool with a
giant god-eating serpent and then
reichardt's face just plastered on the
back of it laura behind it incredible
was consumed by the serpent to seek more
power his voice acting is so interesting
the way he talks is like a snake would
if it could speak english i guess and
yes it's a gimmick fight you have to use
a certain weapon but that weapon is so
much fun to use on him you know giant
wind attacks where you can get one off
and then load up another hit and then
you know it stuns it it's it's sick to
me one of the best fights in the game
music incredible lead up to it i think
there's nothing wrong really with this
fight besides i guess if you want to put
a negative of it being a gimmick fight i
don't think that makes it a negative if
it's well designed which it is one of
the best fights in the game for me
absolutely incredible alright next up is
the lich dragon forta sax you know
obviously the lead up to it with doing
fia's entire quest line when you learn
more of the lore with this lich dragon i
think it brings it to an a for me the
boss fight itself is not hard and
doesn't really have many differences
from the dragons that you see in pharah
missoula but when you learn that the
lich dragon and godwin were friends and
when godwin was slain with the death
room fortisacks went into godwin's brain
to battle death itself within him and
then fortisac's wound up being consumed
by death himself the lore behind it is
one of the best in the game it's sick
the boss arena with the skyline being
like this wicked nightmarish pattern is
awesome music's incredible the fight
itself not much different from any other
dragon in the game besides the red
lightning attacks which are cool i think
it's a solid a great lead up great lore
great music fun not the best combat i
just find a lot of dragon fights in this
game to be sort of annoying but a great
fight nonetheless easy a tier for me oh
here he is baby we got radon radon is
easily an s tier it is the best fight in
elgin ring in my opinion maybe one of
the best fights in all of the souls
games the lead up to it going through
red main castle and having all of his
soldiers singing in unison like a choir
for the festival of champions for people
to go out there and try their luck
fighting against radon to get his great
rune and give radon an honorable death
like stage one where he's shooting
arrows at you and you have to run
through the battlefield where you can
summon all of these other champions in
like a full bum rush battle is so cool
then you get the stage 2 where he jumps
up into the air and rockets down like a
freaking meteor at you is one of the
best moments i've ever had in gaming
ever he offers a tough challenge like a
lot of people struggle with radon for me
i like his moveset i find it easy to
dodge but still a lot of difficulty
there he did get nerfed and then
unnerved whatever man it's still a
spectacle and then you learn more lore
about him where as he was getting bigger
he was sad that he couldn't ride his
beloved horse leonard anymore so he
learned gravity magic so he could hover
himself above his horse and keep riding
him like that's so adorable man i made a
whole video on him i love radon he's my
favorite character in the game and my
favorite boss fight best boss fight in
eldon ring easiest s tier i can give so
now we've got morgot and margit now
marget is more got he was trying to hide
his identity like in and of itself is a
cool lore aspect like if you look more
into it he commands the knights cavalry
and goes out and kind of takes care of
business like a vigilante like a [ __ ]
batman character out in the lands
between to kind of do what needs to be
done for the golden order because he's
actually the only one left in the family
that wants anything really anything to
do with the golden order maybe besides
radon but radon's lost his [ __ ] so
morgot has to be the man for the capital
city for the golden order to kind of
take care of business it's kind of cool
so the market fight i think is awesome i
did not struggle with him as much as
other people did understood the move set
and got it down in less than 10 tries my
first time through i know a lot of other
people struggled but i don't think that
brings any points down on margate itself
because you can just go around the
castle i don't know if a ton of people
know that but you can just go away level
up come back you're gonna be fine so for
me i would give
an a the music the lead up to it into
the castle great boss design i love
margaret morgot same character we see
him three times throughout the game i
believe cause he spawns right outside of
the capital city i would give margaret a
b and more got in a just the cut scene
you get with him walking down the stairs
to the er tree kind of bashing all of
his siblings and the and then he grabs
his sword and reveals his freaking call
of duty damascus sword and he is just
defending his family's line to the very
end after you've learned that he's an
omen banished to the sewers below and
comes out just to take care of business
morgot is freaking awesome now for me
difficulty wise i struggled with him he
is wicked bro he's constantly flying
around the map hitting you close from
far away has lots of range within his
attacks i'm giving him an a he is as
close to an s as you can get without
quite being in there for me the fire
giant i don't know how to feel about
this boss bro listen this fight is cool
it really is
but i hate it i like the scale of the
fire giant but i also don't like that i
can't ever really see him during the
entire fight like i'm always underneath
his toes i'm i'm whacking away at his
ankles you know and then when he rolls
away from you which i don't like either
then i get to see the boss and let me
tell you this boss design the best in
the game potentially the best in the
game just the way he looks his decaying
leg that says like hey come hit this
[ __ ] leg and then he breaks it off
burns it to reveal his like true troll
like cyclops form on his chest is
freaking cool but the fight itself is so
unenjoyable i never have fun fighting
this boss because he has like 50 000 hp
but in my opinion i think he should have
had one big health pool where he didn't
get all of it back in stage two i think
that would have saved this fight i find
it to be one of the least enjoyable
fights in the game although it is a
spectacle the lore behind him is cool
where you learn that he cursed queen
america with red hair which turns out to
be ratagon later if you didn't know that
it's pretty cool boss design is cool but
just the unenjoyable combat of fighting
this guy really brings it down at least
for me you know i can't wait for the
comments they're like this guy was so
easy bro
i didn't struggle with him at all bro
you know i didn't struggle with him that
much either i still don't like hacking
away at someone's feet the entire fight
i never really got to see him and then
he'd roll away and i'd have to run him
down didn't like it so the fire giant is
getting the first c for me now we've got
the dragon lord placidus this fight is
epic the lead up to it incredible the
music amazing the dragon lord gets an s
it is sick where you have to go off the
beaten path to go lay down in some weird
little sand spot right next to a tornado
where it stops time puts you in the best
boss arena in the game the best looking
area like with all the lightning going
on in the background and just this stone
dragon hovering in the air now the move
set of it really isn't all that crazy i
love when it kind of fades away and
disappears just to like kind of whip
around and try and like sneak attack you
or something super cool this fight is a
spectacle i don't think it's really all
that difficult is his hp is pretty high
and but just everything leading up to it
i don't know a ton about the lore i
really want to look into it but dragon
lord one of my favorite fights in the
game love doing it every single time i
think it's a nest here it might not be
for everybody but i loved it man such a
good fight all right now we got malakath
and the beast clergyman so beast
clergyman is stage one going into
malachith the black blade i think beast
clergymen is not fun i i don't like the
first stage of this fight i really don't
i find stage one harder than stage two
because all you have to do in stage two
is dodge until you get that fine you
finally get an opening with this guy but
that cutscene dude
is sick the lore behind this guy is sick
where he is queen america's shadow he is
set to protect the rune of death and a
fragment of it was stolen away and he
vows to himself i will never have this
stolen from me again boss design
incredible in stage two stage one
it's okay i like stage one it's just not
one of my favorites and then stage two
where he's flying around pillar to
pillar doing lips through the air
throwing the black blade at you with
those red attacks is sick nasty i really
do love this fight it is one of the most
memorable in the game but i do not think
it's an s tier it's as close as it gets
just stage one kind of knocks it down
for me i just didn't enjoy stage one as
much as i did stage two we're gonna do
godfrey next i
love godfrey and i think horolu is cool
too but he's kind of cringe i don't know
why and maybe i'm the only one that
thinks this but when he goes from elden
lord to horolu and he stands there and
goes warrior
i cringed i don't know why like the the
line there the voice acting of just that
part right there i was just kind of like
huh
i don't know but the fight itself is one
of the best in the game where he turns
into horolu and just lifts you in the
air and slams you to the ground sick and
then stage one where you can just pound
the earth out and just create
earthquakes everywhere the combat is an
a the lore behind him is in a he was the
first tarnished he was the first elden
lord he was the first consort to queen
america i find it hard to put him
anywhere other than an s just because of
how much fun of a fight this is like the
entire time i'm fighting him i just have
a giant smile on my face i'm gonna put
him at an s he he's just enjoyable every
time i fight him it's a fun move set to
dodge you can dodge every single one of
his attacks sometimes just by jumping in
the air moveset's cool cut scenes are
awesome with sirosh the line on his back
kind of calming him down and then he
just rips him off and he becomes a
warrior it is really cool just that one
voice line kind of cringe we're gonna do
moog lord of blood next now obviously
the lead up through mogwin's palace like
when you're going through nocron city
having no idea how to get up to that
building off in the distance with the
cool purple galaxy stars in the sky and
then you finally learn how to get there
and you meet moog who is just kind of
using mikala in his little egg thing the
lore of moog is sick the boss arena
incredible music
incredible but learning this guy's
moveset was so annoying for me just
because i mean he delays his attacks the
longest of anybody in the game and it
became not fun to dodge but frustrating
i do like the mechanic where he goes uno
dos and then does the
like that is cool where he just takes
away your blood and heals himself kind
of annoying
but cool and there is a wondrous physic
where you can just like negate that
mechanic completely so there is a way to
avoid this if you want to i'm going to
put moog at an a i did not find him as
enjoyable as other bosses although a lot
of him is ester but i just did not have
as much fun fighting him that's my main
thing with him is i don't find him fun
lore music lead up boss arena all asked
here but just the fight itself i i just
didn't like so a tear from oak now we've
got melania blade of mykolo i want to
ask all of you please put it down in the
comments did you like this fight because
i didn't easily one of the hardest
fights in eldon rank probably is the
hardest fight but for a dumb reason i
find hallogtree to be
the most annoying area to traverse all
of the enemies one shot you no matter
how much health you have the cut scene
of her is unreal good though her lore
though is the one of the best in the
game just like radon where from birth
she's been infected with the scarlet rot
and then nuked caleb in her fight with
radon just to go back to the hollow tree
from mykola and he's not there but she
can't really tell and i think in her
lore she's mostly blind now 90 of her
mechanics are fun to dodge except for
the one and you know what i'm talking
about the waterfowl dance ash of war on
her is
broken she can whip that out in a fight
any time she wants and if you're too
close
you are dead now you can't equip a
shield with that ash of war where it
makes it that nothing can get through it
you need to stand there and take all the
hits but even when you're blocking she
still heals which i find stupid she has
two full health bars she can get health
back i do not find this fight fun 90 of
the fight i find fun but when i'm
fighting a boss and i'm running around
all i'm thinking about is one mechanic
that ruins the fight for me i'm just
waiting for her to do it i'm i'm baiting
her out of it i'm throwing kunai at her
just to make her do it it ruins the
fight for me she can do it in stage one
and stage two now the cut scene you get
with her where she's turning into the
rock queen is is freaking beautiful i i
i love this fight but i also hate it and
it's just off one mechanic that i guess
you can dodge but you have to be a
certain distance away or have something
to use that can kind of gimmick
your way out of it i just don't like
that i think it's broken or i'm just bad
let me know i'm gonna put her at a b i
don't find her anywhere nearest here at
all there's a lot of good with melania
but just that one move really ruins that
fight for me so i'm putting her at a b
and then finally we have ratagon and the
elden beast i think radagon himself the
first stage of this fight is an s tier i
love
ratagon i hate
hate
the elden beast i would put eldon beast
at a d or an f if that were on this list
radagon is sick his lore incredible the
lead up going to do his fight of the
urgery amazing his moveset using the
hammer to restore the elden ring his
weapon being shattered barely mended
together by the golden order his body
crusting away from doing so his moveset
is so beautiful where he lifts himself
in the air and just those aoe attacks
are just a spectacle to behold i love
ratagon ratagon is an s tier for sure
and then you get to the elden beast
where this freaking weird galaxy dragon
runs away from you the entire fight the
only difficulty on this guy is the fact
that you can't ever hit him because he's
constantly swimming away from you the
weirdest thing is that you can't use
torrent here why not i've been using
torrent the entire
game it would have made so much sense
not to use torrent with ratagon but when
you're in this giant open space and
we've come to you know at this point in
the game at the end of the game
connecting with torrent just to not be
able to use him in the last fight put
torrent in this fight and this might be
an a to your fight just because i can
run this [ __ ] down that seemed like
such a missed opportunity to just have
that moment with torment you're like
yeah let's go this is the last one so
you can run this guy down now the music
for the elden beast the best in the game
best here i i love that quiet choir
sound it's beautiful it's incredible but
yeah eldon beast is a d ratagon is an s
i'm putting th just because this
picture's here and it's pissing me off
i'm just gonna put it at a d guys this
is my boss tier list for all of the main
remembrances of elden ring i know
there's a ton of other bosses out there
this is my list i hope you like it make
your own let me know what you think down
in the comments make sure to like
subscribe for more elden ring content
really appreciate all the support lately
thank you so much i'll see you on the
next video take care guys
[Music]
you